alright Conan O'Brien here welcome to
serious jibber-jabber I'm sitting here
with the author of five national
bestsellers most notable among them the
devil in the white city in the garden of
beasts and his latest right here
dead wake the last crossing of the
Lusitania which debuted at number one
it's a fascinating telling of the events
that led to and followed the sinking of
the famed Liverpool bound British ocean
liner by a German u-boat during World
War one I'm extremely happy to be joined
by Erik Larson thanks for being here
Erik to like in my small little set it's
so nice to have you I told you this
before the show and I meant it you may
be the only author I can say this to
I've read all of your books
I've read everything I think it's you
and the guy who ever wrote encyclopedia
brown I'm sure my wife can say that so
that's good yeah no I'm a huge fan of
your work I love the way you write I
also love the time period that you seem
to be fixated with is also the time
period that I have long been fixated on
let's let's in general I know you you
deviated a little bit in garden and the
beasts boat mostly we're talking about
when yeah well for me I am particularly
drawn to the period essentially from
about 1890 to about 1920 mm-hm
being the the nexus between essentially
the Gilded Age and the Progressive Era
and I love that era being caught for a
number of reasons one is that I do think
America was very different back then
there was a real sense of optimism this
idea that we could do anything we set
our minds to whether or not we could but
I'm talking about the Panama Canal the
New York City subway system anything
like massive that you wonder what were
they thinking they just took on and
wherever you have that kind of that kind
of hubris wherever you have hubris
you're gonna have tragedy you can have
really compelling stories so that's one
thing but there's another very practical
reason why I love that era and that it
was the the the advent of the typewriter
people typed their correspondence and
believe me it's a big deal when you're
doing
for three or four years so I love that
aspect as well it's I am fascinated with
that era long have been I own old
typewriters own Underwood's and a royal
there are World War One era and I type
letters to my friends on stationery to
anime and when I type them I type them
in this voice of someone it's an I know
it's an affectation but I I typed him in
the voice of someone in 1910 so there's
a lot of hail fellow well met okay and I
send out these dispatches to people and
I do it I love the texture
I love the sound but everything about
that era I don't know if you've been to
Teddy Roosevelt's home boy stur Bay I
have been to Teddy Roosevelt's home that
is when I walk in that house I think
this is one I I love this era of home
the idea of a pneumatic tube or whatever
when I was a kid growing up on Long
Island we used to ride bikes to to his
home and we were just you know tore the
house and walked the grounds it was just
terrific and you really feel like he's
there you feel like he is there
especially in the case of that house
yeah okay so which brings us to
Lusitania is the topic that you chose
for this book why the Lusitania
complicated so it begins with the fact
that I've always had this I've always
had a thing for maritime history you
know who doesn't really especially I
guess little boys you know I mean I was
always a yeah I was always enthralled by
the mysteries of like the Mary Celeste
and the Flying Dutchman and all that
stuff when I was a kid and I've always
always had this interest I would have
done a book about Titanic if you know
Cameron and Celine Dion haven't done it
to death already you know it's it's it's
Celine Dion's my book is fantastic by
the way
forgive them but but the Lusitania was
always there in my mind I was wondered
what's you know what really happened the
thing I learned in high school was hey
Lusitania sunk World War one we're in
that's it but I knew that there there
had to be something more I was put off
though by the fact that I'm you know
there seemed to be a lot of other
material that had been done about the
Lusitania
but I just kept being drawn to it and
the first time I started doing some
preliminary reading in the subject I was
a blown away and you know it was just
really really fascinating still I was
reluctant though because that's not
enough I mean it's it's it's fine to be
blown away but then there still was this
other trailing see if you will of other
things that have been done but was when
I went to an archived for it I like to
parachute into an arc I'm just gonna see
what's there and I realized that there
was something maybe I could bring to
this party because the textured nature
of the archival resources so much deep
rich terrific stuff unlike anything I
had for any of my previous books was
available for this for this subject and
I was just in a small arc up I knew
there was much more elsewhere and I
realized that what I can bring to the
story is suspense
I could I could hopefully I succeeded
but but I saw this suddenly as being a
very different kind of work on the
Lusitania focused on trying to make
people really cent feel as though they
were aboard that ship with these people
real-life suspense yeah you did pull
that off it is a great it's the best
account of actually what it was like to
sail on one of those ships in that era
you get that from the book you also I
know that you were tweeting on the
anniversary of the sinking of and you at
one point linked to footage there's
great there's actual footage of people
getting out of their cars and going in
to board the Lusitania lots of footage
that runs for quite a long time you're
used to seeing little snippets of
footage from that era in 1914 long
footage and you really got the sense
that I feel like I'm there and very
powerful stuff and and yeah
interestingly the cinematography of the
time was a stationary camera so any
motion is actually the ship backing out
of yeah out of this which at first was
really throwing me it was thinking we
were which which hand is which what's
happening here with the camera but the
amazing thing was first of all the guy
one of the guys getting out of the cab
walking into the into the terminal right
up in front of the camera you saw him
now I don't know who he was the odds are
he did not survive right about how
amazing that is to see him and then as
the as the ship is moving out of its
birth to see all these passengers it
frankly was like the start of the the
Titanic film guys real right now right
to the point where one of the stewards
comes out of a door on the on one of the
upper decks and delivers something to a
passenger and then walks back into the
into the cabin I mean it's just like
it's too good to be true yes well he was
the real deal
well here's let's talk about here's what
most kids learn in school they learn
there's a World War America's not
involved it's the first big world war
America's not in it
Woodrow Wilson's gonna keep us out
German u-boats sinks the Lusitania
Lusitania sinks there's a lot of
Americans on board a lot of innocent all
innocent civilians the world is shocked
America says we are not going to stand
for this and goes to war and then with
our help the British and the French
triumphs and what you know and we're
their allies that's what people know not
the case that was even in when I was a
kid one of my favorite movies was Yankel
Yankee Doodle Dandy and in that movie
Jimmy Cagney is playing George M Cohan
and he's walking down the street and
there's a big commotion and someone he
picks up a newspaper and says Lusitania
sunk and he says this means war and goes
right to enlist right right and not true
that said not it's a two-year
two-and-a-half years span or something
between the sinking of the Lusitania two
full years and you know it's funny what
while I was doing my research I would
ask that a few number of people in my in
like my circle who knew what I was
working on I would say okay so how long
do you think it took between the time of
the sinking and the time we got into the
war and the estimates range from two
days to two months when I found that it
was two years frankly I had had this
thing built into my brain or driven into
my brain so long from high school and so
forth that I wasn't even sure that I was
right you know I had to really just just
really look very carefully and make sure
yes in fact it was not for two full
years and then even more amazingly when
Wilson finally asked Congress for a
declaration of war or more accurately a
declaration that a state of war existed
never mentioned the Lusitania because so
much else had happened
you it it was not Pearl Harbor there's
natural Harbor
I think people think often that
Lusitania was to World War one what
Pearl Harbor was to World War two Pearl
Harbor were attacked it's dramatic it
happens on December 7th you know within
a half a day or a day Franklin
Roosevelt's on the radio and and a day
that will live in infamy and everybody
is going to war right this was a very
different situation what's fascinating
and what you do in this book that I was
just absolutely loved is you set up how
many things and this is true of many
tragedies how many small things had to
happen to culminate in the tragedy small
things the the ship for this ship and
the u-boat to meet was a complete it was
almost an accident there was an accident
and swaggered the u-boat am I saying it
correctly swagger speaker speaker the
u-boat captain has pretty much given up
on finding a good ship and he's leaving
the area he doubles back he's going home
he's going home he's headed home and the
Lusitania is not on schedule it was
delayed first of all because the captain
delayed for a couple of reasons
yeah one Wow well one was that the
captain had his niece and actress aboard
and she was still aboard when the when
the the dock crew pulled the gangue
planks away and ship of course couldn't
leave with her aboard so there was that
15 or 20 minute delay but the bigger
delay was it was a two-hour delay caused
by the fact that another ship the
Cameroonian was suddenly requisitioned
by Britain's Admiralty to be used as a
as a as a military vessel and so all the
passengers had to be transferred a
number of those passengers were were
transferred to the to the Lusitania and
so there was that two-hour delay while
all their stuff was brought over from
the airship and aboard now that 2 hours
and even the 2 hours and 15 minutes and
frankly even just the 15 minutes could
have made the difference between life
and death for the shipping for this
chance complete change chancer because
because you know when they did encounter
each other there was there was
prior to the encounter there was heavy
heavy fog and in heavy fog a submarine
stays under underwater deep so it
doesn't get run over by a ship they
would never have seen each other
the fog happened to break just at the
time that these two ships almost
miraculously almost miraculously because
not only did the fog lift the day became
one of the most perfect flawless spring
days you could imagine with the sea as
absolutely smooth as glass yeah
the other thing is that the ship
Lusitania was very fast but it's running
on three funnels not four because
they're trying to save cold yes the ship
had had four funnels and its maximum
speed with all those all the associated
boiler rooms the four boiler rooms and
in operations maximum speed was 25 or 26
knots but because they wanted to save
money they shut down one of the boiler
rooms so that left only three operating
that meant the top speed was only 21
knots so I think okay it's not a big
difference it's like four knots well
it's the difference between it's a full
day's difference and if that boiler had
been in operation if it had been
operating at its published speed the
speed by the way that most people
believed it was still running when they
got aboard definitely there would've
been no chance that the submarine and
Lusitania would have would have
encountered each other now here is the
biggest question I think a lot of people
don't realize this war exists between
Germany and England at the time and
there's an all-out war so these are
passengers taking a British ship from
New York to England the day the ship
sails the German government runs a giant
notice that says attention just we're
letting you know if we if we see any
ship flying the British flag enter
British waters which the Lusitania had
to we we may fire upon it we're just
letting you know that now think
today and they're also saying that that
it doesn't necessarily have to be a word
ship could be any ship because you know
essentially accidents happen it's all on
this right there pretty much saying stay
away from the British Islands or you
could die now you sail at your own risk
you sail at your own risk now can you
imagine today if you were about to get
on an airplane and as you were getting
on they handed you a pamphlet and it
said the destination you're going to
just let you know that the the country
you're headed to we've been warned that
we might get shut out of the sky so you
fly your own risk and that's in today's
newspaper
most people get off the plane why did
people still get on the Lusitania yeah
you know that's what I think and again
that kind of cuts to one of the reasons
that I love that that era they kind of
ship because they had confidence that
the ship was too big too fast to be
caught by a German submarine they'd also
been assured there is there is
considerable evidence that they've been
assured by canard that the ship would be
escorted by the British Navy once it
reached British waters but beyond that
there was also this confidence or this
belief that maybe the old rules of
maritime warfare were still in play and
those rules very explicitly when they
had been agreed by all the seafaring
nations you know forbade any attack on a
passenger liner
they also orchestrated very carefully
attacks on cargo ships as well what
World War one did and what the submarine
did was it began and then thoroughly
completed the process of discarding
those rules
well World War one introduces us to
trench warfare gene guns gas poison
poison gas April of april of 1915 just a
series of air bombardment pretty much
all of the worst things that we came up
with in the 20th century with the
exception of the atomic bomb they come
up with in in World War one and
submarines one of them and it's stunning
to me that people got on that ship and
you described it very well in the book
they had a kind of gallows humor nobody
made jokes well I hope we make it I hope
we
make it but I don't see anybody in
today's climate getting on an airplane
or a ship that's been warned like that
no III don't see that as we live in a
different era now you live in a
different era
maybe maybe there would also be an
element of the fact that today frankly
getting a plane if you story says
they're gonna shoot you down these
weapons that exist today are so accurate
you have no doubt that it would happen
there's no 747 that is that is so big
and so fast that it's going to elude it
you know a SAM missile so let's get in
side the head if we can of the u-boat
captain Tiger Shriekers figure I'll
never get that right the rest of this
I've heard it both ways yeah I'm gonna
call him Joe Joe figure you can call him
Walt yeah Walt this the the the u-boat
captain he sees what is clearly a luxury
liner in his sights and he proceeds to
put a torpedo into it right one of the
things that made it so deadly was that
the ship sank pretty much instantly it
sank 18 minutes 18 minutes there was no
time for people to get into lifeboats so
incredible number of cat what are the
number of casualties
gosh like 1,200 1,200 1,200 casualties
men women children
and a record number of children and
infants aboard yes just horrible sank
and end and then Viger leaves the scene
he knew what he was doing what I mean
did he did he have a conscience about
this let's first let's go into that a
little bit you know what what he what
his war log tries to suggest is that he
did not know that it was the Lusitania
nobody believes that that's the kid well
I won't say nobody nobody believes
that's the case because the Lusitania
was so recognizable a four funnel ship
moreover because of a super-secret
agency room 40 that was intercepting
most if not all of German naval wireless
key
patience everyone knew that the German
broadcasting station at Nordic on the
North Sea coast of Germany was
broadcasting the comings and goings of
Cunard ships including the Lusitania
right so it stretches credibility to
think that he didn't know I think that
he didn't know so he dies a year later
in combat so we don't know God that
fleeing fleeing a fleeing a particular
kind of at least to the best that
anybody can can can reconstruct fleeing
a particular kind of cleverly built
British warship fleeing into a
apparently into a sea mines zone and
then having his submarine blown up with
all hands he he dies do you think had he
lived I mean the crew and I think she
Peter were were awarded that the German
government rather than distinct in
distancing themselves from what this
u-boat had done praised them right and
said in fact they struck a medal and
said commemorating this great thing that
you did which is really hard to believe
because you know when but the met the
medal is a fairly contentious issue has
historically speaking but this is
suffice it to say that the what we know
absolutely beyond doubt because it was
intercepted by the British and I've seen
the actual the actual intercept is that
after Schrager reported his sinking of
the Lusitania and and and bragging a bit
that he did with one torpedo the the
naval command sent him a very
complimentary note saying we're very
proud of you and so forth Germany the
German populace was overjoyed that he
had sucked this ship this is this
paragon of British naval or British
maritime success yeah
but that was the nature of the war you
know the for the Germans they thought
they thought this was the miracle weapon
that was going to you know end the
carnage in the trenches at some point
and you think about it in most of the
big world war one world war two we're
carpet bombing cities we're killing a
lives were killing a lot of civil
that just became that was a new concept
that that came along in the 20th century
which is you decimate civilian
populations that's hey you want to go to
war that's what you do
right you make civilians part of the
part of the war landscape and that's
what the Germans did at the very start
of World War World War one with their
march through Belgium and taking
civilians captive and executing them as
a way of trying to tamp down resistance
the big question this is one question I
want to ask
it's an incredible hypothetical if she
figures survives the war do you think he
is tried do you think he is criminally
prosecuted I think figer if he had
survived the war he would have been
classified as a war criminal how they
proceeded at that point I don't know
yeah and yeah I think I think it's
pretty obvious that that would be the
case because because frankly there were
people who had committed lesser crimes
that were also classified as war
criminals there is some great historical
characters in dead wake that all play
different parts one of them is Churchill
all right Churchill is the First Lord of
the Admiralty right Churchill is aware
that the Lusitania is at risk Churchill
is getting information from room 40
which is their secret service let's
let's qualify this a bit too we want to
be absolutely accurate about what
Churchill knew and didn't know there is
no there is no smoking memo there's
nothing that indicates there's nothing
nothing in Churchill Sam no no cable no
memorandum that says Churchill knew this
was happy well we do know is that is
that elements within the Admiralty did
know that the Lusitania was got
everybody knew the Lusitania was coming
because of this the controversy over
this German advertisement that wasn't
like nobody in the Western world nobody
who read newspapers could have could
could have been you know blind enough
not to realize the Lusitania was coming
right but what what was the question is
how much information that rule 40 had
was actually disseminated elsewhere they
knew the folks in room 40 knew exactly
when the submarine u20s figure submarine
why
left Germany they knew within the first
four 24 hours exactly its position
exactly its position because Shri Gers
wireless man reported the position so
they they had all those I've seen the
intercepts they're all just perfect and
you can even plot them on Google Earth
and see exactly where the summer is
going but more importantly they knew
what his orders were and what his
destination was which was a patrol zone
right off the mouth of Liverpool Harbor
all that material at hand you would
think they would have done something to
protect the ship but nothing was done so
then it has given rise to the really the
main lingering question of Lusitania is
why was that ship allowed to enter those
waters without protection well the
obvious answer if you're gonna be at all
cynical is that and and it's a healthy
dose of cynicism but it's right there
England desperately wants America in the
war that is beyond doubt desperately
Churchill and you it's in the book
there's a moment where Churchill's
speaking to someone and I think he says
look it wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world if the Germans accidentally or
intentionally killed a bunch of America
well he's writing a letter to Britain's
Britain's Board of Trade saying that we
need all the traffic we can get from
America and if some of it gets into
trouble all the better
all the better all the better so
although the Lusitania is sinking didn't
immediately lead to America going to war
against the Germans it certainly helped
certainly grease the grease the skids so
it was a point of some frustration for
the for the British that here was
Lusitania sunk and still we did nothing
there was alive a lot of like oh my god
what are you what are you thinking why
are you not entering this war is it a
potentially dark it's a it's a murky
chapter Churchill's such a fan he's
might be my favorite 20th century figure
just the moat might be the most
impressive 20th century figure to me in
so many different ways
yet there this chapter is murky and dark
and maybe I read it and it's hard for me
not to be a little suspicious
that it's possible well knew and didn't
do anything here's here's here's here's
how I you know I'm again in the absence
of a smoking memo and I would have found
it frankly if if one existed here's the
way I look at it there is a body of
evidence that if you if you presented
this to a court of law and you wanted a
jury to vote you know without a shadow
of a doubt that Churchill had done this
given the available evidence there's a
lot of it but it's all that's all you
know again there's no direct there's no
direct connection to Churchill the jury
would most likely not be able to come to
a to a guilty verdict however if you
turned it around and did what scientists
do they try to prove the null hypothesis
that is to say you try to prove that
something did not happen you can't do
that either
yeah that's the fascinating thing and
that's why I kind of I hang it
truthfully I hang it out on a quite
prominent British historian actually
historian of British naval intelligence
who initially felt that the reason the
ship was in there unprotected was was an
accident it was it was a mistake as he
called it a monumental cock-up but then
later in life and there's an interview
of fascinating interview with him in the
files of the Imperial War Museum in
London and in that later in his life he
changed his mind he said you know I
there's so much evidence and so much
more has come out he said I cannot think
of anything to explain it except a plot
of some sort right but even there he
stopped he said I don't know who was
behind it I don't know who you know what
elements knew of this I don't know if
there's Churchill but there had to be a
plot and he says something very sort of
tantalizing he says if anybody can tell
me otherwise please do you know one of
the things that leads you in that
direction - and it's that you point out
in your book is that most other ships
many other ships entering in the British
waters and those circumstances were
being escorted by destroyers right right
many passengers on the Lusitania thought
that was going to
happen right under the impression that
will be when we get near Ireland will be
met by destroyers and will be led into
Liverpool Harbor so it was a perception
of people traveling it was it was the
the the sort of modus operandi for a lot
of other ships didn't happen mm-hmm and
so the fact that that didn't happen seem
to me incredibly suspicious yeah no
that's not it's not that every ship had
write a script before but a number of
ships including you know the captain was
Captain William Thomas Turner including
including a ship that he had been the
cat right if he had been escorted and in
fact it's funny that at what really adds
to the damning element of the whole
thing at nights on Thursday night
passengers saw a British warship passing
them at very high speed and they they
thought okay this is this is this
evidence of the fact that we're being
escorted well in fact that ship was
racing home because it had gotten alerts
that the that the Lusitania had not
gotten that there were submarines in the
vicinity and I was just going to get the
hell out of there right so that was
another interesting element Woodrow
Wilson another character who's in the
book and I loved it because Wilson fast
I am loved presidential history and
reading trivia and these characters
Woodrow Wilson's a fascinating character
to me and it some of his presence in the
book and sometimes almost play like
comedy because everything else you know
you see all of these dark forces coming
together you know what's coming you know
we all know what's going to happen to
the Lusitania but you see things slowly
moving together and the whole time it's
happening Woodrow Wilson who is
depressed he's lost his wife he's a
widower he's very sad he meets this
woman
Edith bullying Galt and comically falls
in love and starts you know in almost a
sitcom kind of head over heels now let's
let's be careful about comically I mean
the poor guy was smitten yes he was
absolutely smitten this is you know I'm
I come from a different world
yeah I apologize and and you know I mean
he he has just absolutely fallen in love
with this woman in a way that if you
were going through it you would not find
comical at all miss miss guy was lost to
follow up
I mean he write in love with this woman
and you know he had been you know deeply
lonely I mean to the point where one day
he's in New York he's taking a walk with
a friend and advisor in Kenya walk in
Manhattan that's how different times are
notice the President of the United
States yeah they're just walking down
the street you know and when he comes
back he was on the one hand really
delighted by being with just to get out
but he also tells his friend he says you
know you know I can't help feeling that
I wish somebody had had killed me yeah
okay you know this guy was really
depressed right so along comes this this
40-something widow often seen Dupont
Circle in the in Washington tooling
around her elective car apparently quite
glamorous by standards of the of the era
he falls totally in love and he writes
these these amazing love letters you
know very very passionate passionate and
and just pouring his heart out about his
loneliness his need is this that she's
holding him off at first she's like whoa
what what's going on here is the bread
of the United States I'm not ready to
get married you know that kind of thing
and it has really it when she turns him
down for marriage get throws him into a
tailspin and boom just about the same
time loose dingus
well here's in the book it almost plays
as if he's distracted but you know that
that he's that the focus of his life at
that point is this woman has completely
he's completely enthralled with her not
that he would have made a difference one
way or the other
in in you know what happened eventually
to the Lusitania or their or maybe even
maybe more in the response to what
happened to Lusitania but he's a
character in the book who he is the
leader of the United States and he's
going through this very particular time
in his life when he's completely head
over heels in love well there was no
question that he was deeply distracted
by this yeah whether it changed his
reaction to the sinking Lusitania you
know he was fully aware of what was
happening
in world events he was fully aware of
the implications of the potential
implications of Lusitania he was he was
absolutely even then committed to
keeping America out of the war but there
is no question that he was distracted in
fact there was a speech he gave in
Philadelphia and he says at one point he
says in a letter to Edith that that when
I was there I was so he was in such
turmoil over there what had happened in
their relationship that he almost didn't
really he had almost forgotten what city
he was in right and so and it's
interesting I've gotten some feedback
about about that and people are sort of
I heard from a guy who was kind of
appalled that I had revealed this the
secret side of Wilson's life in in the
book and I found that really surprising
because to me to me a big thing that
that what I love about history is that
you got to go with what the record gives
you you know nuance warts and all there
are no heroes no unalloyed heroes
everybody's got you know warts and I
just felt that it humanized Wilson in a
way that I think he he historiographical
he speaking could have used I mean I
always thought I always thought of
Wilson as yes a great president but kind
of a stiff yeah I know he's the guy in
the high collar with Ponce Nez yes and
he's got the the his idealistic plan to
bring peace to the world and he's very
rigid and these letters are not just
love they're their sensual he's like you
can see him as like a sensualist he's
there's almost an erotic quality to have
almost yeah and actually given given the
nature of the time you read between the
lines there there there is an erotic
quality tab although he's not I mean you
know somebody writes the same letter for
they would get to the point a lot
quicker and probably I probably be
texting a photograph whatever but you
know 1915 so if only if only Wilson had
had access to an iPhone exactly who
knows what could have happened
what is I I'll repeat this again well
let me ask quickly before I move on to
that captain Turner
yes captain Lusitania William Thomas
Turner I read your book and I think he
got a raw deal because he is seems like
a very efficient captain he really knows
his business he stayed with the ship
when it was hit absolutely he did and
happened to just be very dramatically he
tried to go down with the ship but was
washed out of the bridge well whether he
tried it down with ship remember the
facts point is he was there on the
bridge with his life jacket on and the
ship just sank from beneath them yeah if
you can imagine that it's fun to try to
fun and it's interesting to try to
picture that kind of a moment because
there you are you're on the ship right
there you are this is your ship it has
you know this is like the catastrophe of
your life of the world you're on this
thing and the waters are so clear and so
still you had to be able to see this
thing fall away from you yeah you know
what an amazing moment and and my
opinion he did nothing wrong but there
was this attempt to someone has to be
responsible so I think the the Admiralty
I think there's an effort to say Turner
well he should have been zigzagging he
you know he he he could have done
something different and there was he was
actually there was a trial were they
well within 24 hours the Admiralty had
decided for for various reasons which
are kind of interesting to contemplate
that Turner was going to be the one to
blame and that's fascinating because
first of all the the publicity value of
the propaganda value of simply blaming
Germany and the submarine commander was
huge
right that's that you know that's in
fact there had been a an inquest already
in kinsale in Ireland you know jumping
the gun on the Admiralty and they had
come to that conclusion that it was the
fault of the German Navy and the dryin
effort
so why pass up that opportunity that
propaganda opportunity to blame a
British citizen a sea captain I mean
this it defies logic yeah and it almost
leads you to believe that they're trying
to distract you from
something they are they yes and that and
that's one more of the little bits and
pieces of evidence that make you think
about plot or conspiracy but again it's
circumstantial but but I believe I
believe that the point of this this this
attempt to attack Turner and and the
head of the inquiry later referred to it
as as a dirty business you know and and
that he resigned his his post but I
believe the the attempt to blame Turner
had a lot to do with trying to keep to
maintain the secrecy of the super-secret
entity this room forty even to the point
where it was allowed the verdict was
allowed to hold that the submarine was
sunk the Lusitania was sunk by two
torpedoes yeah it was not some point to
Tokyo I know that beyond a doubt because
figure and one of the intercepted
telegrams tells us he used only one
torpedo and yet that was kept secret it
is it remain secret even when even when
Churchill wrote his amazing history of
World War one which is really actually
mmm-hmm I agree with you Churchill is
one of the most amazing characters I've
ever come across
not only did he lead a life of action
that rivals and everything Indiana Jones
could have you know come up with here's
a terrific writer yeah terrific writer
not a bad painter either but anyway even
a raconteur and I mean he's he's
everywhere he's the Zelig yeah he's
everywhere and a world one kind of a
screw-up yeah yeah oh yeah yeah but but
even in that history you know decade
after the after the war he's still
insisted on saying two torpedoes yeah
well I there's a very poignant part in
the book where some number of years
later Turner his career never recovered
even though I think he did nothing wrong
just that was my opinion and he comes
across as a you know fantastic captain
and he did everything he could he's the
captain you would want and and yes if
you saw him as that Saturday morning
when you're getting on the Lusitania
about to leave New York if you saw
Turner up there in the bridge yeah be
like all right no no he was the guy he
is you know he is
the the maritime equivalent seems to me
of a Sully Sullenberger exactly because
he's very I like this guy and and he has
all the great qualifications this
happens not his fault but he has to pay
the price for it and there's a very
poignant moment you'll correct me
because I won't get this quite right but
years a number of years later someone
sees him and he's driving like a garbage
scow Oh what happens is ya know it's
very touching they're a bunch of ship
news reporters and this was an era when
when you know New York Times everybody
had a reporter stationed at the war if
the track ship traffic cuz it was so
much traffic right so this was a hot day
in New York the war was still under way
and a bunch of reporters Harbor pilot
incited a bunch of reporters to just
take an excursion to go up up the Hudson
River because he was going to take this
ship I think was called the wasn't the
altona I can't remember the name of the
ship so they go up there and and and
first of all the ship is this ship is
while it's tied up into war if it's
doing something very odd it seems to be
moving on its own because the waters are
very still that's because it is packed
with horses for the war and it was
something that actually had a name was
called a horse storm when something
spokes to horses they would all move
side to side yeah and so the ship would
seem you know this so they pull up next
to the ship and the the side cargo door
opens and there's a man standing there
clearly the captain and it turns out to
be Turner Turner is the captain of this
horse scow if you will and he's wearing
sort of a soiled soiled you know uniform
but it still has his hat cocked at an
angle and he still has the presence of
the old Turner
but he went from sailing one of the
fastest biggest most luxurious ships in
the ocean to within to about two years
he's shuttling horses raina rusted out
Hulk and and that like glad to be doing
it glad to be doing it because the last
thing he wanted to be was on land right
I'm curious as I said in the beginning
I've read all your books
I I love the subjects I also love the
way you write and I'm sure
guess what your process is which part of
the process you're writing okay let's
say let's say you already have the idea
right what you want to write about and
you've done your research
I'm just curious the actual writing that
fascinates me well how much do you do a
day what how does it work here's how it
works the the research I try to get as
much research done as possible in an
ideal world I would have it all done
before I started but you can never do it
because what happens at least for me is
okay I'll be working on the research for
two years and I love the research phase
I really do it's like a detective story
every day
so you can't you know work on this for
two years and there always comes a point
where it's like you know this story
wants to come out my wife who's a
neonatologist intensive care for babies
and also a mother of three daughters she
always equates it to she says she says
you know she says you know it's probably
a lot like you know childbirth you
always get to appointment you're
carrying a child we realize this baby
has to come out right you know and so
that's how it is it's like I gotta start
writing then I go into whatever do is my
page add a mode and I get it very early
for issue you get up it I want to know
if this this is the part I want to know
exactly you get up at 4:00 4:30 5:00
somewhere in that range depends on how
much wine I've had the night before over
dinner
right no but I try to get up very early
and this is something that started back
when I had toddlers now my kids are all
in their 20s but when we had toddlers
you know you're trying to carve out that
space this is before anybody got up so I
get up very early and I write one page
that's my goal at this point one page
it's to it's to to quash that that
person to me that says I got to start
writing get that get that out it's
always one page even if I feel like I
got two or three or four more pages to
go in me that I could just easily do
because I'm a big believer my secret
weapon if I have one is stop while
you're ahead
because the toughest part about writing
is getting up the next morning and
starting again and I I write when I'm in
the writing will actually try to do this
all the time I was writing something
it's you know seven days a week you
gotta get up there get that thing going
except for Christmas like I cut myself
some slack on Christmas but it's one
page I stop even if sometimes in the in
the middle of the
sentence sometimes in the middle of a
paragraph because I know that the next
morning what I get up and I sit down at
my computer and I have my cup of coffee
and my double stuffed Oreo 1f not too
what and ice you have one double stuff
with your coffee that's that's on a good
day a bad day it's too okay so I can
tell the chapters where you've had to
cook I'm sure you can yeah it's really
your prose is over the top it's over the
top so anyways so so but but I I can sit
down and finish that sentence or finish
that paragraph so I am instantly
productive but it's more than that
because of the beauty of the human brain
when you leave something incomplete on
some level somewhere in your mind your
brain is finishing that that thing
whatever it is and in my case it's
finishing that sentence but the beauty
of it is it's not just finishing that
sentence it's taking it out another
three four or five pages and and I just
absolutely swear by it something I stole
from Graham Greene you know I think
Graham Greene may have stolen it from
Hemingway in in a moveable feast
Hemingway talks about he's it's about
his years in Paris and he's talking
about his process and he says I get up
very early in the morning and I write
and he said I know I have this much in
the tank and he says I stop when I have
some left in the tank so that I'm not
staring at the blank page the next day
and so it might just be it's the way to
go I mean it's certainly working for you
it's a universal I guess the worst thing
the worst thing a writer can do and I
often have from time to time I'll teach
a writing course and you know I hear
people who sort of wait around for
inspiration and then they write for like
ten hours right binge writing is the
absolute worst thing you can ever do as
a writer because then you are done the
next day you are you you know it's gonna
be you know a week before you can get
back into it's also write to me when
I've had to write things I there's a
certain amount of dread in the process
whenever someone tells me I just love
writing
give me my I have I've had people say
that to me I love writing I like I just
sit down at my keyboard and I I could do
that all day long and I think no no if
you don't have
if there's not an element of dread there
has to be just I'm not talking about
pure dread but I'm talking about a there
needs to be a dash of dread in there
Joan Didion had the perfect word to
phrase to describe that she referred to
looking at the office looking at her
office door with a sense of low dread
yeah low dread but but I mean it you
know you can love writing I mean I love
writing I love paint you know it's
that's yeah that's the thing
but really it's it's you know I can
truly say that I love writing but but it
is a painful process it is a scary
process there is a lot of dread so what
do I love about it I don't know I mean
it's like satisfying it's just deeply
deeply ties into something in your core
and if you're not a writer you know it
instantly you can't do it you can't you
can't you can't cut it anyway the I just
want to briefly mention the devil in the
White City I absolutely love that book
and I love all your books devil in the
White City was kind of a revelation to
me because it was all the things I loved
in one book that era every single
character I grew up in Brookline
Massachusetts and Frederick Law Olmsted
his office is a five less than a five
it's a two-minute walk from the front
door of my tunnel that I grew up in and
and you describe you know his part in
the book helping to set up the World's
Fair in Chicago he was my favorite
character by the way yeah just a
fantastic character also we've got our
first serial killer HH Holmes you've got
you've got it seems to be an area that
you really love if I'm getting this
right which is we're a young vibrant
optimistic nation but there's evil in
the world and in Holmes's case you have
it's the first time a serial killer can
exist because people are leading a
killer of a certain kind yeah I like the
prototypical urban serial killer I mean
some would argue that some of the Wild
West heroes were
it was but anyway yes and and and and
that's actually what what what drew me
to the project i mean i how i came to do
as a business a ridiculously long
straight i won't bore you with it but
bottom line is i knew about homes in
advance because i was looking for a
murder to write about had taken out a
book from my library in seattle the
encyclopedia of murder doesn't I'll just
tell you I love this is gonna sound
creepy out of context I love murder I'm
and fascinated by serial killers and
then you have this era and it's
historically accurate and I'm just it's
a love note to me and so it's a and I
meant it that way but you know I came
across Holmes early in the process and I
didn't want to do him because he was too
over-the-top bad I don't want to do
crime play I wanted to do something more
evocative of an age more full of you
know like the film Gosford Park that
comes yeah yeah but I heard later as I
was struggling to find my next book idea
I remembered that there was a reference
to the World's Fair of 1893 and I knew
nothing about it I didn't know there was
a World's Fair in eighteen or did I know
it was so powerful in terms of the
national psyche at the time and then I
started reading about the fair and
that's what drew me to the story and in
fact I'll tell you the fact that made me
want to do this book it was a fact in a
footnote somebody had done an academic
book about the World's Fair of 1893 and
it's just the driest there's like a
Marxist deconstructionist whatever of
the German Pavilion you know I don't
know but in the footnote what does I
always read the footnotes of books
because that's where the good stuff
always always is there was a footnote
about juicy fruit gum that juicy fruit
gum was introduced to consumers at the
World's Fair of 1893 I'm a big juicy
fruit gum fan and for me I was just
blown away it's like what this gum is
100 years old and then all the other
things that were introduced I realized
that day that the story I wanted to do
was this story of darkness and light
this good and evil Holmes and the fair
and the same place at the same time that
was going to be the story yeah the title
came to me actually that day devil know
why sitting and stuff
yeah it is now here's a question your
books are and I don't know the details
you'll tell me I'm sure they've been
optioned for the for for for film they
seem so cinematic to me would you do you
want to see these movies these books
made into films is that something you'd
like to see it is it
I would I would love to see them made
into films and in fact to our to our
under option I don't want to yeah I
don't necessarily want to participate
because I think screenwriting I'm gonna
paraphrase this very badly but I believe
Tom Wolfe once said that when you're
dealing with Hollywood you know you take
your book to the fence
hand it over take the bag of money and
run yeah you know because I you know any
writer I know except for one or two
anybody I know who has tried to
subsequently do his or her own
screenplay has wound up with a broken
heart and you know deeply resenting well
your your interest would be different
than the you know the people that just
done Jurassic world we're now moving on
to dead weight are gonna have they're
gonna say is it possible that there was
a dinosaur on the you 20 and you're
gonna say no that they they don't want
no dinosaur no but but but the bottom
line is that the two books have been
have been option one is the devil West
City was optioned by Leonardo DiCaprio
in which I loved I mean I guess I gather
he wants to play Holmes yeah and then in
the garden the Beast which is about the
US ambassador his wild daughter in the
first year of Hitler's rule yeah that's
been optioned by Tom Hanks which I love
also he wants to play ambassador died
now in the case of devil no at City
that's an expensive film yeah that's an
expensive film and it you know it's been
under optional long a long time I don't
I hope it eventually had to recreate
that era yeah and that amazing fair but
CGI that's all I have to say
mmm computers well you mentioned in the
garden of beasts again there's a book
talking about a American a father
William Dodd who is been sent by
Roosevelt to be the ambassador to
Germany and he's living America's first
Nazi German to Nazi Germany and he's
there and he's supposed to sort of take
the temperature and he there's a growing
he has this at the book details his
growing realization that these people
are truly evil right and he's trying to
communicate that to Roosevelt Roosevelt
doesn't really want to hear it or it
isn't convenient for him to hear it or
he's busy with other things he's
inconvenient for him to act on it act on
it and then he has of course his
daughter his daughter Martha Dodd and
that's fascinating because you're quite
explicit about she's very for that era
very sexually free very sexually free
and which as I found was not that
uncommon she was just more out there
more open right she's having a lot of
affairs and including with the first
chief of the Gestapo Rudolf deals yeah
that was one of the things that just
just astounded made the first of all
that there was a first chief of the
Gestapo who was in that role for
essentially a year and was considered by
the diplomatic community to be a pretty
good guy who also fortunately for him
loses that post and get shuttled aside
and so he's I mean had he been had he's
kept that post he had have well spaded
in a lot of horrific things he'd have
been a war criminal he'd have been
killed you know well he would have been
made to participate in a lot of these
things but I don't think we were
speculating here I don't think he would
have I think he left because he was I
mean he was becoming almost ill from the
things that they were happening around
him and you know suddenly at the
Nuremberg trials he testified on behalf
of the Allies against the workouts it's
funny in a way devil in the White City
and is like the photographic negative of
the garden of beasts because one is
about this great optimistic place that
evil enters into and the other is this
truly the beginning of Nazi Germany and
this very malevolent atmosphere and this
really dark environment this pit of
vipers and more idealistic people
entering it exactly to to very naive and
I
realistic people yeah and and with dead
wake you have the great ship and the
u-boat and coming together I mean that's
I think that's a story you tell very
well oh good good so the question is
what's next
how do you find your next topic oh god I
wish you hadn't asked that you know I
don't know what's next I'm looking into
a couple of things but that process of
finding the next book is the single
hardest thing I've done some research
from the era that you like so you can
kind of come up with some ideas for me
I'm gonna pitch you
you've got Battle of Little Bighorn it's
been written about a lot
Custer's a great character but because
it's very hard to find
McKinley assassination now if you end up
doing any of these
oh yeah which we have right we have tape
of me suggest what's the right situation
here no I don't you hate it when in
comedy people are constantly throwing
ideas out you're like please don't
because I might do something that
peripherally touches what you're doing
and later you're gonna say you stole it
from me
well mister you don't want somebody
coming out of the woodwork especially
you know the day that somebody options
your film to say hey that was my idea
you know right right I basically have
pitched two areas if you touch either
one of them
I want $50,000 okay I think that's fair
I'm sure more than fair I think I'll
have my intellectual property lawyer I
think any court of law this has been you
know I do this show because it truly
delights me I I find I don't do many of
them I only do one of these shows when I
really want to do it and the person
kindly agrees to do it and I've read all
of your books and I've always thought
wouldn't it be great to talk to Eric
Larson if only that could happen and so
this is my wish come true
that's nice to hear yeah thank you so
much we have an Internet question here
on Facebook from brandy Swope wants to
know how do you suppose historians will
decode the modern past the information
age where journals are rare access is
limited and the delete button can change
the truth it's a really good question
all I can say is the National Archives
is
archiving tweets that was really but you
know it's it's it's an interesting
question because you know one of the
things that and a very compelling
question one of the things that I rely
on you know deeply is the correspondence
of these area this is another reason I
love that area it's sort of the the
Golden Age of letter writing and and not
just you know a simple two-page missive
I'm in the case of Dwight Harris for
example in this book you know a 12-page
detailed letter to his mother
Theo de Pope a 20-page detailed letter
to her mother
you know invaluable details well that's
all gonna go away that's gonna disappear
but the question is what else will there
be to allow a writer like me to create a
sense of music we laugh at Twitter and
tweets and so forth but why do I is when
something significant happens I know
this now from because I'm fairly active
with with with Twitter you start seeing
it unfold and you see it and there's
there's a real telegraphic sense of
urgency you know it's it's typically
grossly in error but there is that so
that's that's not not a bad thing people
also blog so maybe that's a source maybe
that's the that's going to be the future
analog to detailed correspondence I
don't know but there's also know people
love to keep Diaries and journals now
Journal journaling you know scrapbooking
and all that stuff so I don't know I
mean I'm not I'm not deeply pessimistic
I'm concerned but but historians will
find a way iMovie yeah I'm always of the
how is that the philosophy that it
changes it transforms and transmutes but
it doesn't necessarily it's a mistake to
say it used to be great but now it's
going to be in the future it'll be
terrible there will be a different kind
of history there's a lot of
disadvantages to the tweeting and the
texting and the emailing but one of the
advantages is people are usually doing
it immediately and the most exactly the
most accurate the most accurate accounts
of anything are when people are asked in
Dealey Plaza immediately afterwards what
happened
right when you give them three days
that's when they start 20 years or 20
years oh and and the other another
component of that is not only are you
gonna have the immediate tweets you're
gonna have photographs you're in a video
yeah you know and that's gonna be really
powerful there is a great book that I
found once called I saw Lincoln shot and
it's written accounts of you know there
were 120 people or 210 people whatever
in Ford's Theatre that night they all
wrote accounts of what they saw they are
ridiculous now you read through them and
you read I think like 75 accounts and
they range from the very ones that are
clearly someone recounting who is it's
just saw it and they've recounted it
fairly quickly afterward and they said I
was watching the play then I heard in
muffled noise I looked up there was a
scuffle a man jumped down and he ran
away and you think that's there are
accounts by people there who say okay
here's what happened there was a shot
then a man descended on a rope and you
know he threw down a bomb that made
smoke and then he did this and they're
fantastic they're they're insane they're
absolutely insane but some time has gone
by and they've thought about it and
they've told it a bunch and bars and now
suddenly it's become Lincoln fought
booth for a long time they had swords
and so maybe wait
like a dog was there thinking the dog
was there well that's that's why I like
in the case of one of the things that
drew me is a dead wake and the Lusitania
is because there were a lot of accounts
that were taken right away yeah
depositions statements and so forth a
lot of really detail corresponds I'm
deeply leery of family accounts further
down the road yeah because then suddenly
it's like no not only was the ship you
know torpedoed by the u-20 but u-20
surfaced and the crew came out and
laughed yes I've heard that repeatedly
right it didn't happen they threw
tomatoes at us
yeah that's that's yeah that's I think
you know
i-i-i i think that there will be
advantages to the immediacy yes yeah
yeah yeah that'll counterbalance
something that's missing from response
but right there will be histories they
will be dynamic they will be very good
and they'll be very interesting but you
won't get to do though is pick through
old I mean I know that's what I love is
I love old pages and to think that
future historians are just gonna be
looking at screens
well little I'll tell you you know two
moments like in in two moments in the
garden of beasts one was when you know
the first three three of Martha Dodds
seventy four first files of her 7700
linear feet of documents of the Library
of Congress we're calling cards which
were the sort of social currency of the
era and at first I just said of an okay
fine we're gone I thought Wayman so I
started going down one by one by one
through these cards and suddenly here's
a here's a card from Hermann Goering
okay so what is that wait a minute this
is a card that he gave to her mm-hmm and
that she has now in her file and you
hold that card and you're allowed to you
if you do this the research you pick
this thing out of the thing you're
holding that card that this this killer
had in his hand but the best was you
know I knew she had had an affair before
going to Germany with Carl Sandburg he
was 55 she was you know 20 or something
and I didn't really sort of believe that
that could possibly be the case I never
lots of evidence that said it was and in
her files I came across two lakhs of
Carl snipers here - lots of Carl's
networks there and it really was that
white it's very coarse it was very cool
that's amazing yeah yeah she went on a
date with Hitler well call it a date she
was set up by a point of Hitler's
confidants to have to sort of be there
for lunch and he was to meet her his
grand plan was that they would meet and
fall in love and I wouldn't that be
exciting to have the leader of Germany
being married to the daughter of the
years of masseter didn't happen you know
probably for a lot of reasons that yeah
deeply darkly psychopathic on Hitler's
part yeah just the icon
except if my bad date with Hitler I know
it's a short film I think a very short
film all right well this has been an
absolute treat for me thank you for my
pleasure for doing this for more
episodes of serious jibber-jabber go to
team koco.com slash serious and the book
which is my favorite book in quite a
while
dead wake the last crossing of the
Lusitania it's out there right now and
you're a fool if you don't buy this book
and read it because it's a page-turner
it's a thriller and it's fantastic
thank you so much thank you yeah this
was a really fun
you